so um when joe biden won in november
we started a conversation about what
will joe biden be able to get done what
will be the parameters and the limits of
what joe biden can do
and i made the case that joe manchin
the democratic senator from west
virginia who
is arguably the most right wing of the
democratic senators
was really going to be a problem was
really going to be an impediment was
really going to be a major obstacle and
some people in the audience got it
but many wrote to me and said davido i
think you're overstating the case about
joe manchin here and i maintained no i'm
not no
i believe that joe manchin really is
going to be this big of a problem and we
are now
learning just how big of a problem joe
manchin is going to be
cnn reports democratic senator joe
manchin
on sunday yesterday defended his
decision to vote against a sweeping
voting rights bill
and reiterated his opposition to gutting
the filibuster declaring
in the strongest terms yet that he is
not willing
to change senate rules to help his party
push through much
of joe biden's agenda mansion
said they call him a moderate democrat
which is a very favorable term
manchin said quote i believe that
partisan voting legislation
will destroy the already weakening binds
of our democracy and for that reason i
will vote against
the for the people act further i will
not vote to weaken or eliminate the
filibuster this is what's so
sick about this position it's basically
a both
sides type position
what i mean by that is joe manchin is
saying well
if i am going to do voting rights
legislation
i don't want it to be partisan or
one-sided
but the problem is that the other side
the republican party is using
disenfranchisement
as a tool to try to win elections
joe manchin seems to think and maybe he
believes it or maybe he's just saying it
that if one side wants to pass partisan
legislation
to prevent people from being able to
legally vote
and the other side wants to pass
legislation to ensure
everyone who's entitled to vote can vote
they're both
simply partisan voting rights
pieces of legislation this is it's hard
to imagine
a more depraved sort of both sides
type argument and this is exactly
what i feared would happen with joe
manchin
and it is indeed happening huffington
post is also
reporting about this saying that senator
joe manchin said he won't vote
for his parties for the people act a
bill focused on expanding voting rights
again the idea that
limiting voting rights which is against
the constitution against the law against
what this country is built on
and expanding voting rights for people
who can legally vote
are just two sides of the same political
coin
that is the full end position
toxicity level of the idea of the
enlightened centrist and i'm not going
to be super partisan on either side
when one side is trying to take rights
away you can't say well
i don't want to get involved on this
side either because we're just as
partisan in trying to make sure people
have their rights that's not the way it
works
and this is the sort of you know i i use
the term enlightened centrism
sometimes to refer to online
commentators or whatever who
want to pretend to kind of be above the
partisan fray and see both sides
but this is one of 100 members of the
u.s
senate who is equating taking voting
rights away
as a partisan act by republicans to
giving voting rights as a partisan act
by democrats when the reality is
what the constitution says and what the
law says should be the guiding principle
here so it's
truly unbelievable and disgusting uh
kirsten cinema
on the democratic side also arguably a
problem uh in
in some areas and we'll ultimately see
what happens with this
uh for for the people act but this does
not look
good now i i know that many people will
say well david then
let's primary joe manchin i'm not
against primary anybody as i've said
before
primary whoever the hell you want simply
understand
what the consequences of that might be i
don't see
how a more progressive democrat wins in
west virginia
my instinct is based on the pew polling
data i've seen out of west virginia
that if you successfully primary joe
manchin
with a more progressive democrat which i
don't even know if
if one would win but if joe manchin
loses a democratic primary to a more
progressive democrat
it seems almost certain that that more
progressive democrat
loses the eventual general election and
then you have
a republican in that seat so obviously
this is disgusting
obviously i find all of this completely
disgusting and counterproductive and
retrograde and
it's exactly what we predicted in
november was going to happen so i'm not
surprised by it
but mansion still mostly votes for
democrats so i'm not defending the guy
i'm merely saying you're playing with
fire
if what you might do to fix the joe
manchin problem
loses democrats the majority
in the senate now of course there will
be other races as well when joe manchin
is up so it's more complicated than that
but i'm i'm curious to hear from you uh
about it
because it's not at all clear to me that
the win the way to win this is by
removing mansion and putting at risk
that seat maybe being taken over by a
republican i would be
you know uh my instinct is biden talks
about how great a negotiator he is well
negotiate with this guy biden brags
about negotiating across the aisle
negotiate with your own side to get this
guy on board if you're really the great
diplomat and negotiator you claim to be
and in some senses joe biden is a good
uh negotiator he's done
some some good things negotiating then
convince this guy
what are we waiting for that i think we
need to find a way
to push mansion into supporting at least
some of this stuff
uh because the risk of losing him to a
republican in that seat
to me seems great i'm curious
the risk is great it's not a good thing
to be clear
let me know what you think i want to
hear from you about it one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman